uh jewel evil and then i gotta go back
home to my child speaking
jewel um don't let your kids smoke
jewels not evil about jewel
well there's some group of people saying
okay here's the counter argument
people are going to stop smoking
cigarettes if they use jewel
and an equal and opposite number are
going to start smoking cigarettes
because they use jewel exactly
so like yeah and what is the long-term
effect of getting delivered like
10x the amount of nicotine nobody knows
nobody knows and there's all i mean
years ago
years ago i actually interviewed a guy
who had started a vaping company he had
vaping hardware that was like stainless
steel because he was like look people
are buying these vaping devices
that are just full of nasty chemicals
like you know we know that when you heat
plant like don't microwave your plastic
containers because you're just poisoning
yourself slowly yeah
those vaping like the plastic vaping
devices are basically that
times a million i don't even know if we
know what's in a jewel
let alone that you are still ingesting
an addictive stimulant i have the
perfect way
to manage and nobody at me about coffee
because i'm not having it no
exactly coffee's totally different but
here's the thing they should just make
jewel
a prescription you should have to go to
a doctor and be prescribed it right
solves the whole problem thing yeah if
you if you if they're claiming it's for
to quit smoking right
just like nicotine i think used to be or
the patch used to be
you would consult with a doctor consult
with a doctor and it could be a virtual
consultation it could be like get roman
or hymns or any of these things
we just click on your phone and you go i
want this and then they give it to you
but at least there would be some
throttling that it's not in a store
for kids to buy pina colada flavor right
i mean that's ridiculous and
all and and my kid has as much brand
awareness of joule as he does of tick
tock
you're a house and he is 12. he's
absolutely tried jewel or been
offered it right no
no he's been offered it for sure i'm
sure he's been offered it he's probably
even trying
to kick kids no i know he has because
he's friends with the eighth graders
the eighth graders get kicked out of
school if they bring it to school right
they kick him out of school if they do
it right i'm sure they do yeah it
doesn't mean it's not happening it's
there's
there's so that's one kid told me it's a
giant small yeah that they can't find it
it's a giant oakland public school he's
and you know
without question he has been offered it
or tried it or
will it during the course of this
seventh grade year without a doubt
and then i will kill that child who
gives you all right